we were before we start Nana would were
inspired to finish panel because we were
dragon age inquisition that just came
out or just amount wasn't like it was
all for two weeks and we were talking
about playing it and I had a very tough
time because I started the game as a
Qunari because this was awesome and I
one plays canary and I got two hours in
and I went you know what I don't like
the way I look and restarted the game to
make another Qunari and I got about
three hours and I was like I can't it's
not me and like made a human that looked
exactly like me and then managed to like
power through it and we were talking
about how like you spent how many fun
making your yoga oh I spent like a day
because I feel like I you might like I
was like what are you doing really nice
because i started i started with I mean
so I'm kind of the few people that
actually really like plain as a dude
like i enjoy playing as man and so like
I started as a human man that I did
naari man and then I actually ended a
plane as a canary woman which is like
kind of weird for me because I almost
never do that like you like the female
perspective usually so but we ended up
having this conversation about this
because you know we're like hell I
wonder why that is and why was that you
couldn't get into the game is that and
why was it that i had like decided to
play something completely different yeah
and we assemble this like awesome
Avengers team of smart people here to
talk about this um and we're going to
talk about you know how people were
going to like throw out some numbers and
statistics in my skin check dragon age
to be awesome I'm talking about how we
identify with clear created characters
and how we identify with navy games like
generator or Internet where you have
like you're fully formed human and how
you sort of identify with them and
before we start I wanted to share this
quote from leveling up for dummies by
I I just felt her name I mean resting in
the audience it's broken go up not do
huh there's really great a great article
in the tote stadt net um and he says
here it's up bro I got burned up queer
and how he always played a speech
because he had if I with teaching people
would make fun of him and it says you
have forgiven for anyone whose reality
is cactus quickly it all turns even the
finiteness of video games is in escape
if the rules in the physical world
failed to establish order the physics of
the video game universe can provide a
reprieve by living in breeding these
physics many of us learn something about
ourselves we come back to reality
slightly different people and perhaps
with enhanced problem-solving skills
we're motivated to try and face the
challenges that present themselves in
the real world now I don't think anyone
here hasn't been deeply touched by game
in some way I see a lot of cosplayers
here that have put a lot of time into
you know making what you're wearing then
we just want to talk about you know how
we how we connect to these playable
characters how games are in escape and
oh I know it's messed up nevermind um
and why like why we make those choices
why we plays the other female and answer
she likes to play as male Mitch always
plays as a chick oh yeah what available
yeah I thought I'd you won't follow up I
will get there yeah we can't wait um and
talk to you guys about how they kinda
like die
about how it affects how many consume a
story so at least I here I me this is
our sorry shed because if earlier this
is all of our twitter handle if you want
to follow us to get out of stuff like
that I'm gonna let you to start talking
because you started something in college
and it's a really awesome [ __ ] so I did
you did right oh alright so as part of
my research to sort of introduce it my
main project of studies of an
intersections of gender and authenticity
in rock music video games like rock band
approximate in particular but through
the course of my research I you have to
study sort of wire game studies
literature and even as part of my sort
of sociology class taking one of my
instructors introduced me to a
phenomenon called the Proteus effect
that was coined by this researcher by
the name of Mickey that is also part of
a sort of big wide awesome project
called the Daedalus project that you can
actually search online unfortunately
it's in my car nation mode he hasn't
really been updating it as much since
like the signature like 2008 2009 but
it's over a piece sampled sort of a
self-selected sample of 40,000 MMO
players that will contribute to this
research and you just gathered a
mountain a deluge of data and I'm
picking out some of some of the
they said that he saw there so the kind
of simple project the Proteus effect
basically had there was an experiment
where there were two people in a room
they couldn't see each other and one of
them was a participant in the research
project that was has to do some very
very specific things basically just
communicate with this other person in a
virtual space and the research
participant research subject was
assigned an avatar and was told to
communicate with this other person that
was in this virtual space and they found
that if they were assigned a more
conventionally attractive avatar or a
taller avatar they found that they were
more confident in their sort of virtual
approach they walked closer to the other
character they felt more confident they
opened up more and divulge more personal
information in conversation with the
other player and that was simply because
of what their avatar looked like so that
sort of goes to show that a lot of what
our avatars look
and what they do kind of has an effect
on player behavior and the Proteas
effect also speaks to the idea that some
of those attributes also bleed in to our
everyday lives and the idea that avatars
give us a sense of agency of efficacy um
being able to make change and kind of
kick ass in our world and that bleeds
into are not real life it's all real to
me but in our fleshy life it bleeds into
our pleasure life and it actually
affects people and you know the more
sort of the more you closely identified
with your character and the more
potentially attractive they are the more
likely you are to experience more
confidence in real life like people are
more divulgence even things like online
dating profiles of you're confident
going out there and doing stuff nuts
that's kind of cool other other research
cited in she's basically asked him about
things like character creation of what
goes into building a character and he
found that typically for the most part
people like to be either average or
attractive / graceful when creating
their characters so people are either
interpretive attractiveness they like to
either be average and mostly men are
more likely to be average but then women
are likely to want to be an unattractive
avatar not a lot of people chose to be
hideous and scary we actually went
position get out we were making keeping
the office for making characters for
footage and one of our guys made this is
just an anecdote made it very like an
old lady canary lady that's exactly what
I painter named her grandma Davin's
way better man and she was like and he
played his whole plate there was very
much Davin's and it was awesome I was
something there was something really
awesome about seeing it's like wizened
old canari woman like running around in
the iron bowl that woman a lot the myth
the legend the other amazing example the
folks that made gone home full price
crew they kept tweeting pictures of
their incredibly agent female human
character with it's a deep orange tan
named tuna melt you're like freshman
tanning bed ready to save the world i
was like wow and they just thinkin
getting awesome picture for getting
better and stuff it was quite progress
T'Pol that's awesome awesome um continue
and then in terms of you know what kinds
of things are the most important when
creating a character class type some
people actually am I
get into this like actually say I will
always want to play as a mage or I've
always want to play as a grease or
whatever whatever option is the closest
to that thing that's the thing that I'm
going to pick the class abilities if
they know that maybe you know there's
just a little bit more like a tanking
sort of thing versus a healing sort of
thing you know they kind of want to look
at their possibilities but then the
third most popular reason you know third
most populous in the comes in a
character creation is racist setec so so
the idea of what it is that we look like
yourself is pretty pretty important to
us too so let's all that other stuff and
then in terms of identity projection so
how closely you say that your avatar is
a representation of you and the sort of
flip side of that question was I think
of my avatars as pawns in a game so
people were pretty likely to to think of
their avatars as idealised versions of
themselves we can see that there are
certain of sex differences as well as
sort of age differences you can tell
that it's slightly increases as if
people get older than 35 so i guess like
the older you are and as well as the
younger you are the more likely using of
your
badass version of myself there's
something to that effect and I see that
exact thing kind of play out in my own
research so I did a survey as part of my
rock band research I wanted to interview
some players and see you know what they
thought about the games and stuff and a
third of my respondents when I asked
them what does your rock band rock star
look like a third of them mentioned
themselves at some point so examples
like looks like a cartoonish version of
me or a stylized version of myself a bit
flashy or more performance women and
clothing or make my character to
represent my appearances style as if I
was rocker but then also playing to the
you know sort of rock star type
stereotypes but there was a lot of looks
just like me or as much as we like as
possible or I try to get even my same
clothes or like me in the face but
different clothes are like me or
whatever you know some so things you
know things like that now it's not a
third of the respondents which is pretty
cool and this is you and that's me and
on my form so I don't know do you think
that my other torrents represent
silence version of myself Miller and
Urey that's an awesome name it's
basically combining like all of my
awesome things also like a reference to
life like Melisandre from echo from from
Game of Thrones because awesome you know
firewomen yeah and that's my quisitor I
wanted her to be impossibly fears
especially with her I bingo I wanted mom
I you know the funny thing is that my
don't like her eyes are very easy
fabulous like it's very yeah like a ton
of eye makeup like I would really never
burn me up like that but announcements
have to get Tiger II Jenna childress
great yeah wherever where where's the
sephora in the influence but she gets
done she gets done thank you for sharing
all that that's really awesome before we
get into this this part of the
presentation this is also during this to
you as you did it now I then I did a ton
of research for this gentle and when we
were talking about all the studies of
everything you would this really great
grant about making these and I would
like you to share the rant yeah I
remember when I first got my might like
got like my 3ds like many years ago when
I was trying to create my me and well
first of all like they're just I mean
they're very ground I mean you know
and I'm not round but I'm just saying
that like you know I have like a jawline
and I have you know like things and I
was like flipping through when I and I
couldn't find like the exact skin tone
and I was like so frustrated because I
was like able i canna be a much darker
or wider version than myself but I can't
be me like I can't be like the color
that I look no pun intended i like it
couldn't be like the color that I that I
am and I don't know why I was like
really really important to me and I mean
it was great that I can have like the
same type of like my glasses eyewear but
just like something like that like
having with the proper skin color was
like really important to me but so I end
up like a darker version of myself was
like man okay but yeah this is so this
is from a study I'm going to toss it to
you a study conducted by University and
published in the personality and social
psychology bulletin this past January
actually and it says despite Aventura
seeing whatever an individual wants them
to be that person's personality can come
through and be communicated accurately
to others who we are in real life does
in some extent drive our choices in
deciding how to represent ourselves
online so that's you know you tend to
create or most people tend to create a
version of themselves that they want to
be their ideal self so they get to be
their true self when they are behaving
online yes I mean in the study it was
interesting because I mean it was very
much about how our personalities shine
through as our virtual self so Katrina
funk she found that outgoing and so
individuals for example would create
avatars have communicated their outgoing
and sociable personality so there would
be qualities like open eyes and smiling
and brown hair awareness whether I know
it's like very weird kind of things like
it is like really specific specific
things and then people who were high and
neuroticism tend to create avatars that
actually don't really communicate their
personality accurately um so they found
that people who were I guess I mean a
little less social would creep coffee
three characters that would have an
expression other than smiling and for
whatever reason if other ones smiling
any other expression was kind of seen as
like negative or like not friendly and
then you know having like dark hair and
you know obscuring their their face or
their hair or that kind of thing so it's
it's been a very interesting that like
people people off it even even though
you think like oh I'm just like creating
this character like a lot of it has to
do with who you are and in her life you
know like that that is the thing um and
so we have a show at gamespot cold
reality check and I don't know if any of
you guys have watched that but cam did
this interesting two-part series where
he actually dome into and talked about
why we agreed that but far as we do it
again it was a kind of around the time
the dragon age came out and so we have a
video clip Europe of the the folks in
are you pay off its just kind of
designing there it's really it's really
funny when you've got all of the options
available to you I think I naturally go
towards trying to build me I kind of
always yeah my character that has
essence of me but then is better than I
I am better cheek bones than I am
generally they don't know that they're
not a short or weedy in video game land
so it's kind of like me if I was put
into an automaton machine or something
like that Oh gonna go for two-handed
warrior because I like the idea of just
attacking without defending it so the
option to give myself a bum chin because
of the functions later bunch insider how
much of a button to you on your chin to
look like I'd like it to look quite like
about
gels no I tend to name my character's
after war leaders so yeah so Napoleon
Churchill things like that done Basel
puzzled the destroyer he is ready droog
on very good I'm going with Drew gone
that's awesome yeah so those are like
our co-workers for the link dragon age
yeah and you know this this there was
another interesting article that i read
it was actually a photo project by a
photographer named Scott at Chaucer
Avila the catcher a hard and he he did
this thing where he took a photo so the
photo on the left is the actual and then
used a brain scanner under notes like
some high five technology here where he
had people like think about like how
they would how they would want to look
like in real life and you know it it's
interesting because almost all of them
there's a whole series if you go on the
if you actually Google original idea
you'll find it but I mean some of them
are not so different you see the
gentleman on the top like it's a little
bit different but then the really
interesting one is the child and in the
article that our appendix wrote and
bustle she says subconsciously most of
us maybe not happy with our appearance
or wish it were more in line with the
normative beauty standards what's
particularly powerful for me is concerts
the photograph of a young child cuz
ideal image features a more structured
jawline blue eyes instead of brown that
is very between this image and the
originals let me prove how deeply
ingrained or constant beauty is at
age so that's pretty how long does that
kid she's got to be like fun yeah maybe
like that is apocalyptic that is so
crazy that a child has like that
sensibility to me that is ova this is
awful yeah starts healing yeah and I'm
over here thing about how we can get the
brain scanner like caramels what do you
want to be like there's what a hell of a
gun this is you and then I I did a quick
little poll and I asked a bunch of my
Twitter followers like how they prefer
to be represented in a game and you know
most people either said that like I
don't really have a feel like I play as
different characters all the time well
you know that the second most common
answer was that I like to choose
characters the same gender as me and
look like me just you know family
Alexa's whole thing with dragon age like
you after I have to be human i only know
how to be human so I feel very weird
when i try to play it something else
it's wait yeah and I mean I think moving
on um you know there's a
a man named Mark Wilson who has also
done researching the season two reader
psychology redirect middle middlesex
university and he says what online
worlds allow us to do is taking complete
control of our appearance and allow our
site called you to drive our behavior
what we tend to find is that people who
are more cumple themselves don't have
such a strong preferences for creating
your heroic or beautiful avatar so again
having more of a realistic
representation of himself and it's
interesting too because this is like so
I personally I really like playing as a
malice as week I discussed here but left
and ten percent of females usually play
as men whereas thirty percent of men
like two clicks female so I'm going to
toss it over to you like what like why
is it that you like to play as female or
like what is it that's yeah I mean you
mentioned earlier that you prefer to
play as a man and I suspected that that
percentage would be really low I was
going to ask you what you wanted to do
but i can answer first so I don't have
like a clear answer oh this is why this
is the it's this clear solution but part
of it I think like I play anytime the
option is available to me I play as a
woman in a game like I played on the
plane sorcery on iOS which is like a
tabletop thing and it gives you the
option of getting to pick this dude or
this lady warrior and it affects nothing
except the loop p be plenty jpg of a
character and like the world doesn't
respond to you differently at all but
i'm so cool so the Pirate Bay awesome
what's wrong play the cussing changes
totally it obviously it didn't matter I
think a lot of time when I play a woman
in a game especially like dragon is a
really good example you come back to we
have my career but most of the time when
I play a female I just want to see how
the world engages with women because I
have a pretty clear idea of how my own
world engages with women instead of men
and more often than not a lot of time
good look I'll ever listen to you
because you're a lazy and that kind of
stuff happens a lot like I think this
the dlc for dragging in one when you
could play as the or legion word right
yeah I think I played that as a woman
and i played through most of origins
isn't pan and it was interesting because
i was like under suspicion of Hemlock
you know like you're this or lesion also
you're a woman and there is like a
really interesting dynamic to having to
deal with that that I don't know that
it's not like doing the bid's gets it
sounds weird but it's interesting that
so many games just don't have that kind
of approach when it look with men men in
games are not like well you're just some
man i'm not going to lose that you have
to say like this there's a sense of
authority it mailed video game
characters that we don't have and I
think it's just interesting to see how
game worlds approach them which is I
think some of the reason why I actually
really like playing as an M like it
abdominals yeah like having like that
you know like take no [ __ ] right no
judgment really like oh it's just like
you're one of the guys you know unless I
love doing that I love like this woman
because I get to do that like I get that
kind of thing like that a judgment from
people look now [ __ ] off like I'm not
just some girl I'm gonna look I'm
awesome and I'm gonna cut like conquer
this judgment from you yeah yeah I mean
interestingly enough there's something
called the Laura complex where women
find plaintes woman extremely attractive
because they they get to regain
something we typically are denied in
real life so I mean there is that side
of it as well where you know I don't
know
you prefer I I will always prefer to
play as a lady when I can just because
so much so much when I was growing up I
was like a where where am I within this
world I wasn't much right awesome right
exactly and that that that was like the
yeah moment for me when I was kidding um
and it's kind of interesting i have
another colleague of mine was doing
research specifically on like I think
what like a working title / dissertation
was a kind of spot a real girl in
Azeroth um just awesome so she's looking
like directly I'd sort of like gender
implications in World of Warcraft and
she finds that you know that sometimes
when it comes to like cross-gender play
there's also be sort of like not so
savory aspect of it of men engaging
across gender play hey because like they
went over the stairs alms what for a
bajillion hours might as well look cute
um you know or the i guess like well I
get stuff you know I get stuff because
people think of which is kind of a funky
catch-22 because it's I don't trust that
you're a girl prove it you know you know
sucking a picture or something but at
the same time I trust so much that
you're a girl that I'm going to just
send you gold i'm going to send two
roses and present
kind of like a funky disconnect that
sometimes happens it's also a little bit
vista next in that terms that have like
that person's mind set is like I didn't
take a female character because I'm at
dude they're poor dudes don't pick
female characters like they suspect if
they do is I've waited then it becomes
opening this weird thing or suddenly now
this female is under suspicion because
if somebody who wasn't you decide to
play a girl now I trust anybody yeah
it's my class well the term funding is
and problem this is one of the core
problems is that no one ever goes oh
yeah you're probably girl playing that
guy no one ever does is it's like it's
like there's no perceived advantage to
play a guy because again the classic
problem oh that's the people I really do
have presents for you if you do send me
photos proving it snapchat sorry I who
do you play it me yeah I give them the
chance I've been called out by friends
on this I have a type in that kite that
tank essentially is Cassandra Pendergast
I always play black hair probably sure
girl who kicks a lot ass and that is
just kind of a character but I really
think it's awesome and then in the day
if I guess to thread the way to my fine
we'll just make you one how am I open
thank you so thankfully I'm not on the
diadem crazy carrier so it's Imperium
area soon but the nice thing is the
the that archetype for me is one that's
kind of cool because it ends up like it
essentially for me grounds the
experience into something fantastical in
the sense that it goes against that oh
well here they hear Sears piles and
history books about all these great male
or leaders and all these men men men men
men men I'm like well okay hey I kind of
think that's [ __ ] because I've met
my wife and she is a force of nature and
and I cannot imagine a world in which
she's like oh oh just so no she probably
be up there murdering people with me
which would be nice but the nice thing
is as well is that it helps create a
more fantastic experience for me which
is that it lets me go okay cool this
isn't me this clearly isn't me so i can
start exploring especially in our games
are looking over any obsidian or any
case whatever you're making choices
you're digging the consequences i can do
it from a different perspective and kind
of dissociating myself so it's like okay
I'm not I'm not doing these bad things
of good things I'm just going to make
him call and I often will run through a
character that I've built kind of a set
of rules my most favorite thing mama
bear Shepherd who was super nice if you
were on a group but would [ __ ] in
here if you were in his mouth right so
so in the intriguing thing about that is
that dro Mass Effect one of us our food
because I took her through the whole
trilogy she basically it was pretty much
all renegade it's almost everybody you
dealt with was external to your crew
right when you made your big decisions
it's like all I'm going to end this this
jail cell cuz it's cropped up when it
you know in seven seconds seven but when
you got to mass three she suddenly
started sliding right in the middle
because the majority of the plot givers
were X crew and so mama bear Shepherd
habits and rules which is unprotected
with my crew so Miranda okay we're going
to do the marathon we're going to
and it created it's really intriguing
marker for me which again was nice
because I I would never be that
character that allowed to play that
character because I can kind of keep it
away from myself anyway either way I
started so I have to ask like how how do
you make how does just buy or make these
character creation tools knowing that
it's going to [ __ ] so many people and
just just make this caused so much pain
in anguish and like what kind of like
what kind of flared data have you seen
since Inquisition can always like what
people are doing sure I'm so probably
the most importantly of some of its grip
of nasty yes it is a ridiculous amount
of work to make kerogen especially when
you've decided midstream because we've
decided to extend the project that we
were going to add three new races who
were all different heights and shapes
and anyway so that's why we don't to my
hair styles as you might wanted so there
there's your answer to that but the
thing is it's it's an enormous amount of
work but at the same time what we
recognizes and we've actually seen we've
seen the difference even on dragon age
from cool hey you can be an allocated or
community human to dragon age 2 where
you can be a lock right who is always
human and there was a significant
backlash to that some people that was
really cool they they got okay well it's
a different experience but also I love
being an alpha of being a door so there
you which is sir like that's that's good
critique because it's like okay cool in
and we would get people in a given
articulating why they want to experience
and suffer like me they wanted a
different experience some just felt that
we take an options away and that there
was a value to the options even if they
weren't chosen and not actually colored
a lot of our discussion so one of the
one of the things we did of course is
dragon age inquisition move to the
Frostbite engine so it was a complete
technical overhead right everything
everything that was kind of there had to
be rebuilt from the ground up and some
of our character blades were between
very ambitious so they built the system
we got up to use more targets instead of
slider points to accommodate a number of
different elements to have skin shaders
and such cool origin for so all those
things together create this kind of
combinatorial explosion of how long it
takes to make the character but it also
opened up for us some things like being
able to do darker skin properly because
the clips engine did not do that very
well is Phil it was literally as dark as
a character could be without going into
Squatch land which was just a year
technical thing I don't personally
understand and I was I was assured if
they showed me the results in it was for
my butt but also like being able to you
don't have a much more subtle skinning
shader texture and stuff that we partly
inherited hardly a built up because we
had time to do it from the ground up
meant that we could have front rows and
tattoos and scars not on gen3 but anyway
on the newer machines they have memory
for
maintain it that we could high
resolution models and stuff so
recognizing that we could have these
really high fidelity characters for the
most part also there are some gaps but
allowed us to say okay well this is
worthwhile to do it and so we have it
investing in sliders instead of just
notched positions so that you could find
that subtlety that made it really your
sep one little quirk of the cheekbone is
a standard what have you and what we see
with our players is that there is a very
very deep engagement with with care get
a lot of people you know taking their EA
access you have six hours to play and
like live streaming it and like I went
under there were people still half an
hour and on this six our limited time
thing and they were stepping up in your
character and like wow or they make it
play through a bit of a thing Gokula
that's thoroughly characters I won't
like it so that was really important it
certainly validated that decision and
the other thing we saw and it says this
is a big thing for me coming out of care
doing it's I've come away with this
thesis and I'm trying to gather evidence
for now not positive but that I believe
that character generation is in general
a very intentional thing and one of the
things we did to test that because it's
always good to test and we have we did
we gathered to lab retriever player
choices obviously we don't do it by
player because north orem I think that's
cool but we gather kind of general
statistics and one of the things i
checked was a dragon age 2 versus dragon
age inquisition what was the split of
characters created by general and this
is this problem the most interesting
thing to me because they were
essentially the same about thirty-seven
percent to thirty four percent depending
on region we're thinking right okay so a
that's super significant that is a lot
of female characters being made but the
thinking position did that not all
people notice is when you made your
character it kind of put the deck of
cards and resolve computed Qunari dwarf
and they added the bumper to switch
generous
and which gender went up first was
written so it wasn't always mad
sometimes it was meant right and what I
wanted to see was our players just going
pee and yeah I'm in character because if
they were but we should have seen mr.
distribution were female to male change
right because if it did just been a
dragon age 2 dragon age origins it would
have just been bailed you and warrior
done right and that's basically you have
got we didn't see a change so this for
me is the first night of data for my
theory that when people make it
character they actually engage in it and
I think that you know goes to hey you
bought a role-playing game you kind of
knew where you were getting into I don't
think there's a whole lot of random but
we didn't actually know until we
actually better think of that and also
for me singing the wide range of
characters like well that's a very good
reason for us to keep making wow that's
really cool that's very do you me sorry
is good I was going to do an audience
bowl how many of you spend more than
half an hour making your dragon each
character that's my character an hour
i'm just going to write that down more
than an hour hour and a half oh geez its
ties to ours holy crap you guys so i'll
show me take you mr. my game is up still
three days such see a break
finally I said oh I you know all right
there's a lot of I can't even hear
that's awesome wow it's also very
involved my like listen for you Mike is
since Inquisition came out and you
talked about like the breadth of variety
and fidelity of these characters do you
still have a group of people or like any
like a person who is like oh I you know
I feel like him but I couldn't make me
um I think no I ever received that
feedback what I have seen is you know
like people want to be a cydia not
Danish like they want a specific
variation usually what you see is it was
one that was previously available so
it's kind of a bummer a disappear right
like my city of origin and so don't
repeat that yeah yeah exactly so I have
nothing like personal it's all in
fiction I haven't seen I haven't any of
those nothing I know we haven't seen
major complaint sir obviously I think
that the biggest could you turn is it's
pretty much long hair for failing re
right that's probably the biggest with
warrants are tricky turns out we're real
jerky that's one more Lawrence yeah but
that's that's just it is is there's
always a request for more but I haven't
seen hey I can't do me and I think I
probably owe the other one is actually
like like tight girl hairstyles like an
afro or that kind of luckily that I
don't think we quite as far and but
again that just tough holes one blanket
more hair please sure that one I think
is that was actually pretty good because
it's one where I personally think that
was a miss because we could have done
better on those because they kind of tie
in the skin color and there's everson PA
oh but yeah it doesn't it hasn't been a
particular negativity which is which is
what I'm talking about raises sort of
leads into our Nexus or next point
something else at me and I were talking
about knew we were panini other skin
alum when the feelings that that
influences your character choices when
you say I'm playing mario kart you don't
want to play as Princess Peach your gala
you don't want to be peach but you did
Mario doesn't appeal to you so in honor
of that conversation we have called this
the Yoshi effect I I a hundred percent
like like I would much rather play as
yoshi like identify more with like a
dinosaur that then like the link fences
peach I'm like I'm not like that i'm not
like a girl like that so I'm just I'm
more of like this green dinosaur it's we
i know it's weird but it's just like I
just don't like it and I mean I know
like when like my husband and I are
playing like Mara world like I play as
luigi and he plays as Princess Peach
because for whatever reason having that
they're very complimentary but again I
don't I'm just not as good as like
floating around and he's just much
better at that than I am and so that's
that's just like that's how we roll and
we've got like wiimotes that we have a
peach we believe Ian like we're all into
it like it's you know you have a weird
warrior of hard choices women don't you
do one job on this pretty cool oh I
forgot the story of Michael do it Mario
sorry sorry I forgot it too which is why
I wrote it Oh
no I mean that like I'm you're gonna
love it one dota 2 n ex oh please I
played a lot of dota 2 which has 109
characters League of Legends is the same
thing right like massive Ross hair care
whose tons of variety in terms of you
know Caribous genders races monsters
whatever whenever I'm at a loss for what
to do in terms of like what I won't play
like we're going on a summer roll I'll
biet somebody's salama clay Lena she's
this like awesome redhead sorcery she's
more like Jesus my wife or I'm like I
don't want to play it's like this
brutish like Beastmaster guys like big
muscles Scott axes cool guy like I'll
just took falta Earthshaker is this like
big won't bring Dom looking dog because
I love dogs player shaker because he's a
big dog that's it like I had the exact
same thing where like I don't know what
to do so I'd to fall to a creature of
some kind but you know it's like a weird
psychological thing that we both turn to
Mike do you see more people making other
races and they do human no human is
still nominally the Caribee see yo
interesting he was a boring I nomas are
so venturous the event dress which I
wonder if I wonder if it's a result of
like in dragon age and mass effect as
well and most games the player avatar is
predominantly humanoid like bipedal you
are one face I wonder if that's art of
like if I'm going to play a humanoid
character I don't want to have hordes of
monsters playing like a human I have
thanks missile I did I don't know I
think I think it's here if you're hard
at it in the dl or and you're kind of
like
and I know this world and that kind of
stuff there is the human is it's like
it's easy mode right yes that's it like
you give in this inning position are
like a normal family whereas the elves
are like oh I'm an outcast that my tribe
or you know I'm just here infiltrating
where the boards are all like part of
criminal gangs and it's like they have a
tougher go yeah and we we try to call
out a couple points over the course
again like the different for table
celebs routes actually easier than its
way harder is Qunari because you take
could you take like a 20 point standing
hit just by showing up and so you know
sport standing open to a non-combat
ending if you want it so can already has
a top I'm getting that on the other hand
dating Sarah is super easy if you're a
canary patient is Dutch speaking of
fetishes we're going to talk about
boners now we have this conversation via
email as we're planning this panel on
the idea of sex as a goal and whether or
not knowing that you're going to get
thumb later on in a game that affects if
that affects the way that you create
yourself and I know you have a lot to
say about this I think for me it's less
about like how who I want to make like
by decide if I you know I see a trailer
or like you guys have like relationship
a love interest trailers the past if I
see something other carefully
interesting I look the romance them I
don't think I tailing my character so
much to that experience as I do I just
decide like all right I'm going to go
out of my way to talk to this person at
that point I'm not talking that person
because I find them interesting in the
more I do anything like here we're going
to bang yeah and especially a problem
like achievements it made that a huge
issue for me because I think I'm you're
like mass effect has the paramore
achievement and it's the last thing you
get before you mean the game it's like
that you you spend all these instances
after Bay missions talking to somebody
in the cargo hold and it's becoming
increasing
heated over time because you're picking
all the flirtatious options and the
payoff is at the very end it's all right
we did it now let's go hit save the
world and that's like in the context of
the universe that's often a problem in
games for me because there's urgency and
there's danger and there's bigger
problem is that getting laid and either
i just when i was going to pick your
brain about how that comes to be because
it more often than not and games
especially if I where there's getting
better like you are developing actual
relationships with these characters but
why for so long video game relationships
have built that way well it's okay so
typically what we're whenever we're
doing any progression within story stuff
ultimately under the hood there's a
computer down there and I computer
responds to ones and zeroes right is
this true is this true and so when we
started to build on the first time
around we complete ride early days we
tried a couple of different approaches
one was sing the right thing at the
right time and I was not like a one and
done and then we were finished so that
was like certain certain comets had to
be made at certain points anytime we
tried something that was more
complicated simply because we try to
figure out the space I don't know if
anyone like a gauge of G hero Evan EG to
you probably didn't unless you had a
patch that Vance ended up making because
that thing was a tangled mess right jr.
would break 80 different ways because
you left the party and all yeah this
guy's nodding he goes yeah I gave it a
try to hear it was virtually impossible
to actually like character the course I
make me learn just shining down and
talking you again but as we as we
proceed to do it we would try it kind of
like okay we're going to do beats that
happen at moments then we tried the more
like all right let's just track kind of
a blowing kind of overall approval over
time I am a stuff you say that's the
fact that it basically was adding a
reducing to a score and those both of
those approaches feel pretty painting by
nature so what we tried to do with
Inquisition and this is just other no
growth and that is that we decided not
to look everything to approval not to
look at everything just to talking not
to look everything to specific time
needs but instead to use a mix of all
three for all carriers so Iron Bowl has
a block of different things that you can
interact with since these points cradle
you Simmons our example one of his one
of his better moments where which can be
friendly or is a chance for you to flirt
is it is triggered by you actually
killing a dragon which impresses and
they takes you out drinking because that
was overexcited right and that's out of
the bowl stuff and it's a chance to
flirt but again with him he basically
shows no response to your flirting he is
him like well he doesn't warm up he
doesn't do anything until you've heard
it enough times reached enough point the
game and gone during you with them and
met the chargers and then he shows up in
your bed references okay I keys
I don't know if you write and then and
then and that gets all kinky which is
great because it's super consensual and
things are cool and again got bleach did
an amazing job with him but but that's a
very different template that means
before because it's a mixture of
different inputs that to my Micah Hyde's
the game eunice of it and remove some of
that light okay good you were giving me
some which to be fair absorbent sweater
yeah you know and you know college eyes
plug it was it was horrible but it was
again super Guinea and it felt kind of
like you implying sex I think one of my
favorite video game relationship things
is I played there all of mass effect as
a man because I'm heretic say we well I
got straight were clearing awesome but i
played through that mass effect two is
when they can choose kelly chambers and
i met chambers and she's this like
awesome warm bubbly personality on this
ship full of like bomber people because
the world is in a bad place and I was
like ah look she's great like I'll spend
time talking to her and the choice is
kept reflecting like the increasingly
poor Texas choices nothing all right
cool and I was falling a path on the car
I don't have build a relationship with
her you cannot have a relationship with
Young Achievers is a man and I thought
that was really awesome that it's like
you can have that response to her and
you can engage her as though you are
like I'm gonna seduce this one if she's
like no dude and I am gay and I'm not
giving you at all that's awesome that's
so Cassandra house I had saying about an
awkward discussion I can flip over
that's so good so are
yeah and then and then sarah has
probably some of the best let downs oh
yeah cuz we're into the same thing so no
yeah they say okay so we like actually
with again those it i think to the
texture because they make out what
character of you chosen to play it adds
a degree of like wow yeah okay i came
from quick with these characters
anything just like yeah that's the best
thing is when a game can convince you
that like this relationship is real in
the context of eviction and not as a
result of some systems yeah or you know
people like you go into a game like this
or any RPG you like I'm going to play
this kind of character so that I can
achieve this kind of relationship at
that point for me like you're already
doing it wrong and that's about for me
like I just don't like to proteins that
way so there's there's one thing though
that we started one more thing that I
that I did and I kind of like super
wrestle with myself for for a while
before Inquisition came out of it did
release here are the romantic
combinations puppets on you yeah that
was me does me somebody happy and you
know if it's like if it's maybe going to
be bad news like about soulless I want
me to get you all night rather than the
team right it's better that way because
the team has a lot of very important
work to do and i can go drinking to
forget but so that so releasing that
kind of information was well as things
where we actually come in like a lot of
long discussions it's a good thing is
that spoilers should we do this because
it is spoiler epic side I pissed the
roadblock was saying okay so here's here
it is it's coming and you know there
will be enough text that you won't just
glance to it and essentially I said the
reasoning behind this is that the game
is big like it is and we're not this
isn't a marketing beat this is just
literally us recognizing that this game
takes a long freakin time before you
even making it to like the point where
oh the soul experience could even begin
for an example and so this was only in
the females right that was it so if you
roll like a canary to Nellore or killing
the people and like you were like man
sold us i'm so excited with libraries
romance or whatever and you're like 60
hours into the game or 40 hours into the
game and put it in work week i feel that
that's pretty disappointing if that's a
vector of an experience you want to have
right so i basically grabbed it will all
kinds of spoiler paper and say okay so
but if you really need to be sure or
maybe you ask your friends and they can
only show you the one or something i
want to give people an opportunity
because because I thought that would
kind of suck Edgar like yeah you can
roll a major role of age but it's those
right like that's that's not fun right
there so that was tough time I'm still
not quite sure who's right though maybe
we should just said nothing but it was
going alright kulkarni visit is
appreciated um so our last point before
we like get out of time we mentioned at
the beginning the hail the green is sort
of touch briefly on like how we identify
with pre-made careful like Laura Cochran
even great and I know I personally I
have problem for about two years where I
thought I was lightning from final
fantasy 13 it to the sureness my family
and my friends a cosplayer
filter for that I'd I'd like our pink
like I did I did the whole shebang and
it was awful and you have a really
interesting story about Melissa Portland
I like theirs theirs it's whatever but
you're white but while I was so okay
this is probably going to know it might
appear in some sort of party before for
something in the next few weeks but case
in point my husband and I have play
games together and it used to be like
him in what virtual world playing at FPS
and being playing World of Warcraft and
know where the to kill me until we found
Borderlands which had the best of both
worlds it was amazing and he would yell
at me to do things like reborn
undercover which is weird and then I
would tell him things like why did you
not open that mailbox there's something
important in there there's something
important in everything open everything
and he rolled Roland I will Louis
because I said hey red hair and tattoos
Dave and I always played it's a mage
wherever possible into was the closest
mangy thing I had and then sure enough
and borderlands 2 comes out and I were
like accidental ship becomes cannon
spoilers like like it was it was such
like a like a really big deal because
it's been like so much time with those
characters and and to the point that I
kind of like lobbed off half my hair and
and I started cosplaying as her and it
was just really really cool like that
that game is just wrapped up and so much
equal awesomeness step that I had kind
great about you [ __ ] well actually
speaking of I was actually really going
to happen I haven't really had much
chance to play with it like I'm excited
about like the Nisha character because
well I mean it's like it's an Indian
name I don't know [ __ ] you know but it's
like it's kind of minded media they were
like material person person you're the
[ __ ] the Nisha call yeah yeah but it's
cool because she's like this brown girl
and have like almost never happens you
know so that was like really interesting
to me but I mean so because I generally
like playing like a guy like I don't
know like so GTA series Carly one my
favorite like games ever and playing GTA
5 like being able to be like three
different types of dude was like so much
fun for me like I really really loved it
like I really liked being like Trevor
because he's just like the worst right
like it's just but it's just so fun it's
like fun being my trash I never get to
beat white trash like so fun like you
know I don't know what that's like so it
was just like this like awesome
experience and like I just really got
into it and like I don't know I just
like really really enjoyed it and got
like invested in it it's like I don't
even like I'm always on the other side
of it were like not I'm kind of physical
character does not really me but I
really enjoy the experience of that how
many of you have played over watch on
the show floor oh god guys till her
name's off me cut the line so you know
I'm Joe play is sariah sipping I was
That's exactly Moses
they have a very good spread of
characters and they're all pre-made they
have if your own backstory their own
personality and the ethnicity and the
just like the body types that are being
being represented in that past are so
amazing and I know when that came dealt
won that game comes out I'm going to
play as aria she was actually introduced
this weekend and she is a former Russian
bodybuilder and she's this tall like
stocky muscular woman and I immediately
like I could not like he said when you
play overwatch switch characters every
round I didn't know it anyplace aria I
could do Joseph I'm not like I enjoyed
the burritos I'm not a stick like and
she was this like beautiful like buxom
buxom woman and I'm like i identify with
her because she is someone that I like
feel like I can identify with that I
look like so I just think that decades
is doing like so many good things for
that kind of representation is
interesting because Blizzard has
traditionally been very bad yeah
fighting games are interesting in this
place I played my games for I mean
mostly street fighter for many many
years and another favorite but I used to
always play you know I because back in
the day there weren't that many
characters and he now is like oh my god
so many but like I always say as were
you and like that was that was who I who
I like plain as
when like Sakura was an option sounds
like oh what's like a female version a
cuter girl version of and I was like a
teenager at the time so I was like
really excited about that but I don't
know I still always tended to fall to
reuse some types they elope I don't know
there's like this like feeling of power
like because you just there's this whole
thing I mean I need you ma'am it's like
in you're in college order there's whole
thing of like how much space people take
on a screen and like what that means and
what it means for presence of that
character of that person and a TV show
or whatever it is and so like you know
being a big character being someone like
thank you for example you know like I
mean I'm usually just button mashing my
plane isn't but I just feel powerful I
just feel like it's large awesome
powerful man
you